Hallelujah.
Hey.
Hey. Hey.
Hey
everybody.
the mystic realm of death.
This is a subject that is fascinating.
You know, I'm a scientist
and when you discuss this issue of
death,
then one wonders what is death? And the
only definition that you can find for
death is a negative definition. Death is
the opposite of life. Now what is life?
Life is something that is not dead.
That's it. You cannot really say what
the difference is. If you have a cell
and you look at the cell, the one is
living and one that has just died has
exactly the same chemical bases, has
exactly the same enzymes, has exactly
everything identical except for one
small thing and that is that is dead.
And what that difference is is something
that no scientist has ever been able to
explain. It's been possible to freeze
life and to bring that life back, but it
has not been possible ever to have death
return to life. Once that is gone, it's
gone.
And the Lord God formed of the dust of
the ground and formed man of the dust of
the ground and breathed into his nostril
the breath of life. And man received a
living soul. Genesis 2:7. Is that what
it says there?
>> Nope. Doesn't say that. It says, "And
man
became
a living soul." So in other words, if we
look at this text, we have two
components.
There was dust of the ground. That's the
matter, the material substance which by
itself
has no life. And then he breathed into
his nostrils the breath of life. He gave
him life. He gave him that something
which made the non-living living. And he
calls it then a living soul. So in other
words, the combination
of dust of the earth plus the breath of
life is equal to a living soul. That's
the formula for life. Now this breath of
life, is this a living entity by itself?
Is this something that exists in another
world floats around and is a living
thinking intelligent entity or is it
merely the ru the fire the metabolism
that something which makes something
alive that's a very important question
now the bible says you don't receive a
living soul when this combination takes
case you become a living soul.
So breath
breath spirit
breath of man spirit of man. So the word
breath is often interchangeably used
with the word spirit ru spirit. So this
breath is something which makes it
alive. Now breath if you think about it
in scientific terms is oxygen exchange
and oxygen exchange in the sciences we
call metabolism.
So a living cell differs from a
non-living in that it has metabolism.
There is something happening chemically
in there that nobody can duplicate once
that metabolism spark is gone. No
scientist can create life. He can put
all the substances together but he
cannot produce life. So that breath that
metabolism spark is something that comes
from God. Every breathing thing that's
exactly what it means. And the word
spirit there Strongs 07307 ru spirit
wind breath mind blast air anger cool
courage that which makes you alive this
metabolism this ru this spirit this
breath this wind.
So is it a living entity this wind or
does the individual
when he is combined with the dust and
this ru does he become the living
entity? Well, the formula said he
becomes a living soul, nephesh, soul,
life, person, mind, creature, the body,
himself, yourself, you become you.
That's what it means. There are the
definitions straight out of the Hebrew
concordance. So when you are alive, then
you are a living
nephesh. You are nephesh. You are a
living soul. You are the entity. You are
not two entities. You are one entity.
And the Lord commanded the man, saying,
of every tree of the garden, thou must
freely eat. But of the tree of the
knowledge of good and evil, thou shalt
not eat of it. For in the day that thou
eatest thereof, thou shalt surely die.
Genesis 2:16-17.
Now, what does that mean? Does that text
mean that on the day that you eat of the
fruit, you will be separated and go and
live eternally on cloud9 as your spirit?
Or does it mean the two will be
separated?
The nephesh will again disintegrate into
the material and God takes his ru his
life his spirit that he gave you that
gave you life he takes it back it
returns to him and then what's left
dust
that's it
very important that we understand this
issue that's what the Bible actually
says is. But the devil says something
else. The devil's lie, you shall not
surely die. Genesis 3:4. So
God says you will surely what? Die. And
die means not live. Right or wrong?
>> Right? But the devil says, "No, no, no,
no, no. You will not surely die." which
actually means that you will live.
Now in the world today, what is
believed? That you die or is it believed
that you live forever? If you've been
bad, you go to the hot place. If you've
been good, you go to the good place.
Isn't that what the world believes?
So in other words, it's not so bad, you
see, because it's just discarding this
body, but I continue to live. So what's
the big deal? What's the big deal? I
live eternally anyway. But God said,
"You will die." The devil said you will
not die. So one of them is lying and one
of them is speaking the truth. Romans
6:23 says, "The wages of sin is
>> death."
death. For God knows that when you eat
of it, your eyes will be opened and you
will be like God. Even better. So the de
devil promises that when you die or when
you eat of the fruit, you will not die.
You will have eternal life and you will
become bigger and better and greater and
like God. So that's really something and
a lot of religions believe exactly that.
If you take Hinduism,
then you do not die. You just continue
in the spirit world and you return again
and you get better and better and better
and you wipe out the karma of your past
and eventually you reach a state of
godhood and you become a living god and
you can be worshiped on this earth. They
worship them all the time. Isn't that
so? So you get bigger and better and
greater. My question always is why is
this the living u
why are the living conditions becoming
worse and worse and worse and worse if
they're all getting rid of their karma
over all these millions of years and
getting better and better and better.
They're not doing a very good job of it,
are they? I don't think they're doing a
very good job of it at all. So your eyes
will be opened and you will be like God
knowing good and evil. Genesis 3:5. So
the devil said something
and today the whole world believes the
lie rather believing what God says.
You are of your father the devil and the
lusts of your father you will do. He was
a murderer from the beginning and abode
not in the truth because there is no
truth in him. When he speaketh a lie, he
speaketh of his own, for he is a liar
and the father of it. John 8:44. Well,
the Bible doesn't mince words as to
which one spoke the truth there in Eden.
God said you will die. That means
if life living entity consisted of the
dust of the earth and the spirit, the
ruach, the breath, the life spark, the
metabolic process, God takes it back.
Then you cease to exist. You die. You're
just dust. The devil says, "Huh, uh-uh.
You will continue to live. You will
never die. In fact, you will be like
God.
I am the God of Abraham and the God of
Isaac and the God of Jacob. God is not
the God of the dead, but of the living.
Matthew 22:32.
Let's read another one. Mark 12 27. He
is not the God of the dead, but the God
of the living. Ye therefore do greatly.
For he's not the God of the dead, Luke
20:38. but of the living for all live
unto him.
Now this is fascinating.
So God says that he is the God of the
living. Now he mentions even some names
over here. Abraham and Isaac and Jacob.
Are they living or are they dead? Now
they're dead. They've died. But God
regards them as living. Does that mean
that they live as spirit entities now?
Or does it mean that in Christ they are
alive?
In Christ
there is eternal life for them. But the
question arises, when is that life going
to be given them? And the answer that
the Bible consistently gives is in the
resurrection.
The Bible teaches
death, but if you are in Christ,
resurrection to eternal life. The other
systems teach when you die, you have it
instantly and you continue as a spirit
and you live eternally as a spirit. But
then they some teach that when you are
resurrected the spirit has to come back
into the body. So has to come down and
he has to rise again as a body. So how
will they live in future as a body
again? In the meantime they live as a
spirit but they never die. It's not
consistent with the biblical teaching.
But the bottom line is that God does not
count those that have died in Christ as
dead. He counts them as living because
in him they have life. Now, Osiris, the
God of the dead,
Osiris was worshiped not as the God of
the living, but the God of the dead. In
fact, the greatest thing that could
happen to you was to die
because when you were dead, you were
with Osiris
and Osiris was the one who gave you
eternal bliss. So Osiris was the God of
the dead as opposed to Jesus Christ who
is the God of the living. Tat Moses III
is attributed with the guide book of the
netherworld, the Umayat.
And he is the one who wrote the system
on which the Gnostic faith is is based.
The whole Osiris cult that we looked at
last night to some extent is based on
the God of the dead. So you had two gods
in ancient times. Yave, the God of the
living, Christ Jesus, Yave the Savior.
So that's what it means is the one who
is the God of the living and you can
only have life in Christ because in
Christ and no one else there is life.
But Osiris was the God of the dead. So
the god of the dead was actually a god
that concentrated on death rather than
on life and veneration of the dead was a
system that is attributed to Osiris.
So in this religious system you had the
various deities and Osiris was the one
who weighed you in the balances to see
if you were found wanting. So he is also
the one who is the judge. Now in the
biblical system who is the one who is
the judge all judgment has given unto
whom?
>> Was given unto Jesus. Jesus is the
judge. He's the God of the living. So
Jesus says, "If you are in me, you have
nothing to fear. I am the judge. I'm the
advocate. I'm everything rolled into
one." Osiris is the one who weighs your
works
and sees whether your works, your good
works outweigh your bad works. And if
your good works outweigh your bad works,
well then you went to the good place.
And if your bad works outweighed your
good works, then you went to the bad
place. So the teaching of a bad place on
the other side and a good place on the
other side is based on the Osiris cult
and we have to compare the two very very
carefully.
So it was taught that Anubis, for
example, this doglike god is another
form of Osiris, the god of the dead. And
when you died, he is the one who took
you through the processes that occurred
on the other side. So the pharaoh when
he died, his whole clan was put to
death. His whole staff had to die with
him. And they probably died quite
happily because they were going through
to the other side to serve in a much
more exalted capacity than they served
before. So they did have no fear. We
have religions today where people are
prepared to do all kinds of things to
get into that state of bliss.
Even blow themselves up just to get to
that state of bliss. They have no
knowledge of the teachings of the
scriptures in this regard or they would
never do such a silly thing.
So after death it was taught that life
continues much as it does today without
the burdens and uh you carried on in a
blissful cloud9
situation. Now the veneration and the
consultation of the dead is prohibited
in the scriptures. Deuteronomy 18:10-12
says, "There shall not be found amongst
you anyone that maketh his son or his
daughter pass through the fire?"
Now do religions today still do
fireworks? Yes or no?
>> Yes, absolutely. Just go to the east.
And what about our religions in our
world? What about western society?
Do you know that uh in the education
process in big industry today, firewalks
are very common as you have new age mind
trainers that train you for positions of
authority within the business world and
they take you through the firewalks
constantly and uh you overcome these
fears. This is something that God
forbids.
Or that uses divination or the observer
of times or an enchanter or a witch.
It's great to be Harry Potter or his
friends these days, right? To be a witch
or a wizard or a charmer or a consulter
with familiar spirits or a wizard or a
necromancer,
someone who consults the dead.
For all that do these things are an
abomination
unto the Lord. And because of these
abominations, the Lord thy God does
drive them out from before thee.
Deuteronomy 18:10-12.
Wow. Now, if you were so highly exalted
and so spiritual and so close to God and
so wonderful, if you were dead,
then what does God say? Why were you not
allowed to talk to any of these or
communicate with the spirit world on the
other side? Why were you not allowed to
be a wizard? Why were you not allowed to
do these things? Why not?
Because when you were dead, you were
dead.
Then who is acting the part of the
living? When you are really dead, who is
it then?
>> Satan. It must be Satan the deceiver and
demonic forces. So when you call upon
the names of these deceased, you are
calling up this not the spirits of the
dead, you are calling up the spirits of
demons. And they have no problem in
impersonating those that went before.
Anyone
who came into contact with a dead person
or a grave was considered unclean and
could not take part in the temple
worship. Now that does not mean that if
someone died in the family you could not
bury him because they buried their dead.
They buried Abraham. They buried Isaac.
They buried Jacob. They carried the
bones of Joseph back with them to the
promised land. So it has nothing to do
with burying your dead or something like
that or paying last respects to someone
who has who has passed away or to show
grief with those who are crying. It has
to do with veneration. It has to do with
worship. So God
separated the worship systems that
involved the dead as far as the east is
from the west from his worship system.
There was to be no question as to any
veneration of the dead whatsoever.
Whatsoever. It had to be totally
separated. So God said, "No one will
come into my temple and worship over
dead bodies." That doesn't mean you
can't bury someone who has died. I'm not
talking about that. It's talking about
worship.
And whosoever touches one that is slain
with a sword in the open field or a dead
body or a bone of a man or a grave shall
be unclean seven days. Numbers 19:16. So
you weren't to come into contact with
graves. Why was this so? Why did God
make this very strong distinction?
Because paganism
believes in the veneration of the dead.
In Africa where I come from, all the
great religions are based purely on the
veneration of the dead. The ancestors
are the ones through whom everyone is
worshiped, including Christ. Catholicism
fits like a glove into that situation
because Catholicism teaches the
veneration of the dead. There's saint so
and so and saint so and so and saint the
other and saint whoever
and you go through the saint to God and
now in the African system you go through
the ancestor to God in the in the in the
Indian in the red Indian culture do
exactly the same thing it's based on
paganism that's all they know so God
made a very clear distinction and said
listen there is no veneration of the
dead in fact I don't want you to have
anything to do with this. You cannot
come into contact with these with these
entities of the dead and presume them to
be active on your behalf because they're
dead. Dead is dead.
And the Lord said unto Moses, "Speak
unto the priests, the sons of Aaron, and
say to them, there shall none be defiled
for the dead amongst the people."
Leviticus 21:1. Very, very clear
distinctions.
Very clear. But the world today
does not believe in the death of the
dead. They believe the lie that the
devil spoke and they believed in
continued life after death. Some in
bliss and those are the ones that you
contact. The Bible says none of them.
None of them contact with any one of
them is akin to witchcraft. is akin to
witchcraft. Now let's have a look at the
cathedrals of the world today. The
cathedrals of the world today are all
built on ancient pagan
worship sites. No cathedral may be
without dead bodies and graves or else
it is not a cathedral. A cathedral is in
fact a morttery. It is a graveyard. And
God said, "You're not to come into
contact with the graves of the dead when
you come to worship him. Stay away from
the temple for seven days. You can
grieve. That's fair enough. But don't
come to my temple. I'm making a
difference between paganism
and the God of the living. I am not the
God of the dead. I'm the God of the
living. Stay away from this this issue.
I am the God. Worship me. Don't worship
through any dead man's bones.
Well, the cathedrals are not only
ancient pagan worship sites. All the
great cathedrals, NRAAM, St. Paul's, all
of them, all those cathedrals are built
on ancient pagan sites.
And they were all built in exactly the
same fashion as was the Druidic system.
You used to have a channel of stones,
huge pillar stones leading up to a
central circle in which was the central
stone, which is the circle with a dot on
it, the ancient pagan sexual symbol of
unification between the two deities, the
male and the female, and propagation of
life through the fertility. Right? It's
pretty weird. Now the ancient cathedrals
are built exactly the same way. These
pillars that you have the giant pillars
in a cathedral represent those stones
and in the ancient cathedrals in the
past you always used to have a circular
garden behind with a stone in the center
as in the drudic system and many of the
cathedrals today still have that. So
when you look down the passage, you used
to come into the circle down the
passage. These great pillars on the side
represent the channel of the sun and
they're built in that way as well. And
you walk through and you walk through
the regeneration cycle into the sexual
occult setting of the circular grove
where the hidden god either Pan or the
god of the woods Diana or one of them
was situated. And as you walk down this
aisle, you are walking on the bodies of
men. It is necromancing.
It is the age-old drudic system. In
fact, you are not allowed to say a mass
in any in any church setting in these
religious systems without there being
the bone of a dead saint under the
altar. You have to have a bone because
only through the dead man's bones or a
portion of him, whatever the portion is,
can you actually find access to God.
Wow. That is something that God strictly
forbade and something which is generally
practiced today. So in the Dudic system,
this is what you had there. You had the
circular stone hedge. In the past, there
used to be the channel, the walkway of
stones on either side and then they
covered it up on the sides. They put a
steeple on the front and that was the
cathedral. It's built and based on
drudic worship of the ancestors of the
dead. These are modernday druids. And
you will see that they are dressed very
much like nuns. Interesting. Well, here
is one of the great cathedrals in
Europe. And you will see here is one of
the circular gardens. This today placed
on the side. And in it, when you go
walking through it, you will find the
graves. And you will find the ancient
sites. In the cathedrals, you will have
numerous bodies of whoever it is, kings
and queens and dead people and saints
and just anybody as long as there are
lots of bodies, but largely important
people. So here in these cathedrals,
you'll find all these graveyards,
something which God strictly forbade.
Here you have the tombs. This is Edward,
the kings lying in state with the pine
cones and all the regalia that deals
with paganism.
This particular one over here is the
bone of a saint. Uh I've been in many
many cathedrals and I've always wondered
who is the particular saint that is
under the altar because in the altar
where the mass is said you have
particular bone structures. So here for
example uh this one comes from the
cathedral in London where under the
altar in the basement you will find
these tombs and these relics. And if you
ever have the opportunity then go into
the basement and have a look for
yourselves. You will find them there.
There is not a church, a Roman Catholic
church or an Anglican church or one of
the paganized churches where you will
not find these bones. And they will make
them prominent. As you enter into the
churches here in this Roman Catholic
Cathedral, there's a giant tomb right
there. You walk into the graveyard.
Something that God said you should never
do. Here is an interesting cathedral
that I found in Germany. There's the
symbol of the sun god by the way. There
is the altar. So either in the altar or
under directly under the altar there
will be a tomb. Now normally you don't
see it from inside the church. You have
to go looking outside the church for an
entrance or a side entrance somewhere.
But in this particular one the entrance
was right in the churches went down and
then you can go under the altar. And of
course, there has to be a tomb down
there or else you cannot say the mass
because it's veneration of the dead. And
I went down and stuck my camera through
there just to show you the tomb. There
it is. And the altar is up there
in the top. That's worship of the dead.
Some nice tombs. This is in in the
cathedrals in London and in Europe,
wherever you go. And then as you walk
down the aisleways of these cathedrals,
you will find that you are walking on
dead men's bones all over the place. And
this is John uh Gent and he died on the
13th of August
1767.
And you will find others. Now in this
system the god of the dead was either
Seb in the Egyptian system and later he
became Saturn the Saturn god and the
symbol of Saturn was the skull with the
two bones which is also the symbol of
course that pirates use and that is the
symbol of the god of the dead but that's
not the symbol of Jesus Christ. This is
a Roman Catholic cathedral in Europe. At
the top there you have the fernx is a
symbol of Lucifer. That's not a symbol
of Jesus Christ. And there you have
Anubis. Don't even hide it. Anubis, the
god of the dead, the god of the Egyptian
dead. So choose. Are we serving the god
of the dead? Or are we serving the god
of the living? Either one or the other.
Now what about Catholicism in general?
the pope amongst us, the Bennett
beatatification of father Joseph Gerard,
just as a modern day example when a
human being is uh beatified, declared to
be a saint. And you'll be surprised at
who is declared to be a saint. Anybody
who does something for Rome is declared
to be a saint. They're discussing the
beatatification of Conrad Adin now. So,
wow, soon you'll be able to pray to him,
too. Well, in any case, here again is
the symbol of the sun in front of him.
And in Catholicism, the veneration of
the dead is very, very prominent. That's
why the ancient pagan religions
associate readily with Catholicism. In
this particular monastery, here are the
bones and the skeletons of all the monks
that have ever lived throughout the ages
of Catholicism in this particular
monastery. here. When you died, you
didn't get buried. You were set aside
for a while until you were cleaned up
and then uh you became part of the
decoration.
And when you go into this place, it is
claimed that you can benefit from their
righteous works because in their lives,
these monks con um did more righteous
works than they needed to go to heaven.
So there's an excess of righteousness.
There's sort of a basin out of which you
can take a little bit to top up your
lack of righteousness. And I'm not
making a joke. This is Catholic
doctrine. I know I'm a Catholic. I was a
Catholic myself. Was a Catholic. Here
you go. Take some of this righteousness.
Walk through there and pray to the dead.
Here are all the bones and the skulls
standing over there at G Capuchi in
Rome. Well, this is bringing the
ancestors to mass. Priests say they are
tired of being black sheep of clerical
family and want African rituals included
in their services. Well, that's what's
happening all over the world and in
Africa in particular and the ancient
ancestral form of worship is alive and
back today as it was in the beginning.
So you can pray to these saints. You can
ask for them to mediate. And you can
borrow from their excess righteousness
to top up yours. And Jesus Christ, who
is the only mediator between man and
God, is marginalized. You never talk to
him. You know, you have to have a
special audience through all these dead
men's bones to get there. Now, when you
go to Islam, it's exactly the same
religion. Islam is also the veneration
of the dead and it is exactly the same
as Catholicism in this sense. That's why
behind the scenes there is no problem
between the religions. This is the
famous Umayat mosque in Syria. The
oldest mosque by the way. This is the
mosque that the pope chose to make his
um apology for all the deeds that uh
happened in the past in the name of
religion. And I stood in this mosque and
I was stunned to see what was going on
here. Here you can see the Muslims
praying at this particular shrine. This
is a fascinating shrine because in this
particular shrine here in the Umayatak
mosque there lies the body of an
interesting personage and in fact it's
not the whole body. It's just the head
of that particular entity that is here
somewhere buried under one of these
pillars and that's what makes the mosque
a place of worship. Uh any guesses as to
whose head is in that mosque?
>> John the Baptist.
Now you might be stunned to hear that
John the Baptist
who is revered by Christians
should be here in this mosque revered by
Muslims
and finding special grace from the head
of John the Baptist. Well, the pope was
here and also paid special homage of
course to this particular skull in
there. I don't know whether it really is
the head of John the Baptist.
Fortunately,
the Roman Catholic Church is not totally
devoid of this luxury because they have
the arm of John the Baptist in one of
their cathedrals in Istanbul. You see?
So, between the two of them, maybe they
can find some of the rest of the pieces
as well. I don't know. But isn't it sad
to have this ritual of praying to the
dead?
For dust thou art and dust unto dust
thou shalt return. Genesis 3:19. In Adam
all die. 1 Corinthians 15:22.
So all mankind that was in Adam is
subject to death. That's the bottom
line. And death is non-life. You're
dead. And the Lord God formed man of the
dust of the ground, and breathed into
his nostrils the breath of life, and man
became a living soul. Genesis 2:7. Then
shall the dust return to the earth as it
was, and the spirit shall return unto
God who gave in it. It returns to God.
It's not the entity. It's the ruach, the
breath, the lifegiving principle which
returns to God and then you cease to
live. Ecclesiastes 12:7.
All the while, let's read what happens
here. Job 27:3. All the while my breath
is in me and the spirit of God is in my
nostrils. That is Hebrew parallelism.
that equates the breath with the spirit
as one. In other words, he's saying this
is the situation. This is the situation.
Repeating it in other words. So, Hebrew
parallelism as we have seen also in the
concordance equates this lifegiving
principle the spirit with the breath the
lifegiving principle of God. All the
while, my breath, this lifegiving
principle, the fact that I breathe means
that I am alive. And the spirit of God
is in my nostrils. This breath is in my
nostrils. That is why I'm alive. If God
should take this breath, this lifegiving
principle away from me, what happens to
me? I'm dead. I die.
Listen to this. Ezekiel 18:4,
the soul nephesh
that sinnth it shall die. So people say,
"Aha, I die but my soul remains alive."
No, no, no. The soul is the entity that
is alive. That is the body plus the the
ru plus the spirit. And when I die in
sin, I die. The soul, the nephesh, the
living entity dies. It ceases to exist.
So the soul is not a separate entity
that goes and sits on cloud nine and
plays the harp. I always thought that
was going to be terribly boring to one
day die and sit on a cloud and play the
harp. And uh when I was for a while
completely away from the church and went
through my atheistic stance and then
back to the church again, these issues
always fascinated me. The King James
version uses the word soul 1,600
times, but never once uses the term
immortal soul. Doesn't exist. There's no
such thing. Only God is immortal. The
Bible declares that death is asleep 53
times. Of course, you are asleep when
you are in Christ because Christ is the
God of the living. So when you die, the
Bible says if you are in Christ, you are
as though you are just asleep. God will
wake you up at the latter day. Let's see
what happens when you die. But a man
dieth and wasteth away. Yeah, man. Give
us up the ghost, the ruah, the spirit.
And where is he?
Job 14:10.
But man dies and is cut off. That is the
New King James version of the same text.
And man expires.
And where is he? You see this word ghost
over there is the word expires. It's a
very good translation. So look carefully
at your translations. The word expire
means to breathe your last. Isn't that
right? He breathes his last. So the
breath goes from him. The life principle
goes from him. Hebrews
die. Give up the ghost. Dead, perish,
expire, be about to die. That's what it
means.
And how long will he remain in that
state? Job 14:12, "Till the heavens be
no more, they shall not awake, nor be
raised out of their sleep."
That's the teaching of the Bible. So
when you die, it is akin to a state of
sleep. For how long?
Until the heavens are no more. And when
will that take place? By the way, the
Bible says that when Christ returns, the
heavens will roll up like a scroll. So
at the return of Christ, there is an
awakening from the sleep. So you die,
you know nothing, you sleep until the
resurrection day. You will not awake,
nor will you be raised from that sleep.
Let's have a look at the
practical example that Jesus left
behind. John 11:1, our friend Lazarus
sleepeth. Lazarus
was a friend of Jesus Christ. Jesus
Christ was a friend of Lazarus. Our
friend Lazarus sleepeth. But I go that I
may awake him out of his sleep. Now the
disciples thought, well, this man is
talking about a sick Lazarus who is
asleep. Lord, if he sleep, he shall do
well. How be it, Jesus spoke of his
death, but Jesus called it asleep. But
they thought he had spoken of taking of
rest in sleep. Then said Jesus unto them
plainly, Lazarus is dead. See, Lazarus
is dead. But for Christ, Lazarus was
what?
asleep because Christ is the God of the
>> living, not the God of the dead. So here
he was, he was asleep. Now what about
Abraham? To Christ, Abraham is what?
>> Sleeping. That's what it's all about. So
Lazarus is dead. But to Christ, he was
just asleep. God does not forget the
dead. They are in Christ. He has the
hard disk. He has the full record of
your entity as you were. And when he
says restore,
there you are perfect like you were
better.
Lord, if thou been here, my brother had
not died. John 11:21. So now when Jesus
comes to Lazarus, he's confronted by
Mary, who says, "If only you'd been
here, he would not have died.
Thy brother shall rise again. John
11:23. Jesus comforts her and says,
"What's your problem? Don't you have
faith? Your brother will rise again."
And let's listen to her answer. She
answers John 11:24. I know that he is
now in heaven and one day he will come
again and return to his body at the
resurrection. Is that what it says
there?
No. No. It says, "I know that he shall
rise again in the resurrection at the
last day." So, what is the biblical
teaching about death? The biblical
teaching about death is you die
and it's a state of sleep, total
unconsciousness, but Christ will raise
you on the latter day. And to show that
he had power over death, he raised
Lazarus from the dead. But Lord, by this
time there's a bad odor, for he has been
there four days. John 11:39.
But he said to him, Lazarus, come forth.
And Lazarus came out and said, Lord, why
did you call me up? I was having such
fun in heaven.
Not a word. Not a word. Lazarus
continued with his life. He as if he had
woken out of his sleep. There's no
question that he was not in heaven or
anywhere else during that time period.
And when thy days be fulfilled, thou
shalt sleep with thy fathers. 2 Samuel
7:12
to Daniel. He said, read the last verse
of Daniel. He says, Daniel, you shall
sleep and you shall rise again in the
latter days to receive your allotted
inheritance. They're all asleep in
Christ.
Is there a conscious existence after
death? We have to answer this question.
It's very important.
Well, Psalms 146:4 says, "His breath,
this ru, this lifegiving principle, the
spirit of God returns to God, goes forth
forth, returns to his earth. In that
very day, his thoughts perish." So when
you die, there's no thinking, no
cognitive thought. For the living know
that they shall die, but the dead know
not anything. also their love, their
hatred, their envy is now perished.
Ecclesiastes 9:5 and 6. So when we are
told there's a haunted house over there
and it's haunted
because the guy who lived over there had
an affair with so and so and so and so
and then they killed each other and now
the place is haunted because they're
constantly bickering and fighting and
are envious about the relationships that
they had prior to that. Is that biblical
or is it unbiblical?
>> It's totally unbiblical. Totally
unbiblical. For the living know that
they shall die, but the dead know not
anything.
Also, their love and their hatred and
their envy is now perished. So when
Prince Charles
of England consults Lord Mount Batton,
who is dead,
who's he talking to?
He's not talking to Lord Mount Batton.
He might think so, but my Bible says
that Lord Mountbatton won't help him
anything because his thoughts have
perished. He's not there. The dead
praise not the Lord, neither any that go
down into silence. Psalms 115:17. So
when you die, people say that person is
now in heaven in the presence of God
praising God. No, not so. Psalms 115:17
says, "The dead praise not the Lord,
neither any that go down into silence."
There's nothing down there. Nothing.
Just silence. For in death there is no
remembrance of thee. In the grave, who
shall give thee thanks? Psalm 6:5.
Nobody. You cannot praise God after
you're dead. If you want to praise God,
you have to praise him now. You won't
get a second chance later. There's no
purgatory where you can burn off some of
your venial sins to find better favor
with God. For that which befalleth the
sons of men befallleth the beasts.
There's no difference between the way an
animal dies and man dies. It says that
which befall the sons of men befallth
the beast. Even one thing befallth them.
As the one dieth so dieth the other. So
animals and man die the same way. They
all have one breath. One breath. Now,
many churches teach that people when
they die go to heaven, but animals don't
because they don't have a soul.
That's not biblical.
There's the Bible text. And the Bible
may not contradict itself. Everybody
dies the same way. That animal has
exactly the same metabolism as any human
being. Any scientist can tell you that.
I can transplant an animal's organ and
put it into a human being and if we can
get rid of the problem of rejection,
they'll probably survive. So there's no
difference between the way an animal
lives and the way a human lives. The
only difference is that a human makes
cognitive decisions in his life and is
subject to the reckoning of God and
therefore in Christ or out of Christ. So
animals die the same way as humans. They
all have one
spirit ru lifegiving principle so that
man has no preeminence over a beast.
Isn't that interesting?
We must read the Bible carefully. Isaiah
38:18. There is beautiful harmony
throughout the Bible. For the grave
cannot praise thee. Death cannot
celebrate thee. They that go down into
the pit cannot hope for thy truth.
The decision has to be made now, not
like later. Whatsoever thy hand findeth
to do, do it with thy might. For there
is no work, nor device, nor knowledge,
nor wisdom in the grave, whether thou
goest. Ecclesiastes 9:10. So when you
are dead, you are dead. If you want to
do something, do it now. If you want to
make right with someone you've had a
problem with, do it now. You can't do it
later. You can't come back as a ghost
and sort it out and fight forever and
ever and talk about haunted houses and
whatever. That's demology. That's
spiritism.
Imagine
how much confusion
could be avoided if people accepted the
biblical doctrine on death. What a
wonderful relief. I was so relieved when
I heard that my mother
was asleep.
And I have confidence that one day she
will rise in Christ. I have confidence
in that. My mother didn't know all the
truth. But I know that God will judge
her according to what she knew. My
mother died when I was 12 years old. And
I was always worried when I did bad
things that oh wow mom I'm sorry. Please
close your eyes that you can't see this.
Now I know my mother's asleep. What a
relief. She doesn't have to worry about
me and freak out and panic on the other
side whether I'm going to do this right,
that right, or the other wrong. She's
asleep and one day I'll have a nice chat
to her when the Lord ra r ra ra ra ra ra
ra ra ra ra ra ra ra ra ra ra ra ra ra
ra ra ra ra ra ra ra ra raises her from
the dead. That is my hope. This is an
old joke, but it's still quite funny.
Paul Adams 1902. Stop my friend as you
go by. As you are now, so once was I. As
I am now, you soon shall be. So prepare
yourself to follow me. to follow you.
I'm not content until I know just where
you went.
Well, it's quite cute. What about this?
Now, this is the birthplace of modern
spiritualism.
Upon the site stood the Hidesville
Cottage, the home of the Fox sisters.
And this is their stone, their morttery
stone. March 31, 1848.
There is no death, there are no dead.
Is that God language or serpent
language?
>> It's serpent language. Very interesting.
There they are, the three fox sisters.
They're the ones that started modern
spiritism because they heard the
wrappings and they were tap tap tap tap.
And then the spirits were tap tap tap
tap tap. And so the communication, the
modern communication with the spirit
world opened up to the western world. Of
course, in the ancient cultures, it had
always been there. In the African
culture, in the Egyptian culture, in the
Babylonian culture, in the eastern
culture, consultation with the dead was
always practiced. But for the modern
western Christian mind, this was the
opening wedge.
Spiritualism says that the dead know
more than the living. And the serpent
said unto the woman, "Ye shall not
surely die." Genesis 3:4.
Spiritism says, "You know more. You know
more." In this, this is now quoting
them. As in many other Bible passages,
the devil told the truth and the Lord is
in error. Ew. Sprung spiritualist. Wow.
So the Lord lied and the Lord was in
error. The devil is the one who is the
truth. That's great.
Spiritism claims that the dead are not
dead. The fundamental principle of
spiritism is that the human beings
survive bodily death. And that
occasionally under conditions not yet
fully understood. We can communicate
with those who have gone before. This is
J. Arthur Hill, Spiritism, History,
Phenomenon, and Doctrine, page 25. So
they say you're not dead. The Bible says
you're dead. Well, one of the two is
wrong. Right or wrong? One of the two is
wrong. Spiritism claims that the dead
communicate with the living. There is no
death in the graveyard.
I have frequent talks with the dead. I
cannot doubt that people live after
death, for I frequently talk with them.
Sir Oliver Lodge.
Wow. In fact,
spiritism is alive and practiced at the
highest levels of society today.
at the highest levels of society, kings
and queens and emperors and presidents,
they all practice it. Very interesting.
Something which the Bible forbids. The
progressive thinker May 18, 1929 said,
"What spiritualism is and does, it
removes all fear of death, which is
really the portal to the spirit world."
This is eastern mysticism. This is
Osiris worship. This is Anubis.
It teaches that death is not the
cessation of life but a mere change of
condition. Spiritualism is God's message
to mortals declaring there is no death.
That all who have passed on still live.
That there is hope in the life beyond
for the most sinful.
Ah
so carry on sinning. It doesn't matter.
You can fix it up later.
That's interesting
that every soul will progress through
the ages to heights sublime and glorious
where God is love and love is God. And I
always say look at India. Look at
Kolkata.
How thousands of years of reincarnation
has improved the quality of life there.
It's ridiculous.
It's the most pathetic lie in the
universe and the devil spun it and the
world believes it. That's the fact of
the matter. As a cloud vanishes and is
gone, so he who goes down to the grave
does not return. He will never come to
his house again. Job 7:9 and 10. You
cannot talk with the dead because the
dead know not anything. If you talk to
the dead, you are talking to a demon
who says,
"I am whatever I am." I've got tapes of
these. My father-in-law was deeply
steeped into spiritualism. He was a very
prominent newager. He believed all this
stuff. I can tell you stories that you
will not believe. Don't miss the lecture
tomorrow night. The new age movement.
Wow.
His sons come to honor and he knoweth it
not. What do we preach at the graveside?
They're looking down upon you. Don't be
sad.
And they are brought low, but he
perceiveth it not of them. Job 14:21.
What comfort. My mother never saw my my
mistakes and my bad moves or or
whatever. She's asleep. When a few years
are come, then I shall go the way whence
I shall not return. Job 16:22.
Until the Lord comes and as it is
appointed unto men once to die, but
after this the judgment. Hebrews 9:27.
Whap, there goes reincarnation. Goodbye.
Either you believe the Bible or you
believe the lie. One of the two. There
is no reincarnation.
There is no cycle. There is no second
chance. It's now or never. You are
appointed once to die. And then there is
a resurrection and it's judgment whether
we like it or not. And when they shall
say unto you, seek unto them that have
familiar spirits, and unto wizards that
peep in that matter, they peep and they
make funny noises.
Should not a people seek unto their God,
for the living, to the dead? What are
you doing consulting the dead? Isaiah
8:19. Talk to God. Don't consult the
dead. Don't consult the stars and the
spiritists and the wizards and the
necromancers to the law and to the
testimony. If they speak not according
to this word, it is because there is no
light in them. Messiah 8:20. If they do
not speak according to the Bible,
forget about them. Forget about them.
They're lying.
So spiritism
and death
are in unity, but God and life are in
unity. Regard not them that have
familiar spirits, neither seek after
wizards to be defiled by them. I am the
Lord your God. Leviticus 19:31.
Maybe Harry Potter movies are pleasant
to some, but they plant seeds in young
minds which ripen to make fruits of
unrighteousness.
Spirit entities coming out of the class,
howling through the places, good
spirits, bad spirits, good witches, bad
witches. What a load of rubbish.
And our kids are doing these things and
doing them where in church even. Can you
believe it? Leviticus 19:31, "Put not
your trust in princes, nor in the sons
of man, in whom there is no help. His
breath goeth forth, his ru, his life,
returneth to his earth, goes back to
dust, and that very day his thoughts
perish." 146 3 and 4. So it was the
ancient Egyptians that believed the
pagan doctrine of immortality of the
soul. And they taught this fervently in
Alexandria. Now, do you know what's
interesting?
That the Jews were just like people
today. They thought they could get a
better education at the universities of
the world. So, they went to study the
theology of the nations. And many of
them received their education in
Alexandria. The Sadducees were such a
class. The Sadducees believed that when
you died,
you went straight to heaven and there
you sat on Abraham's lap. How
comfortable it was. And if you had
something to pray about, you prayed to
Abraham who was dead to communicate to
God. That's ancestral worship. You pray
through Abraham to God. You use an in
between one. And they taught as they
learned here in Egypt in Alexandria that
when you died you went either to the
good place or you went to the hot place.
That's Inubis Osiris worship. The
Pharisees on the other hand believed in
what?
>> They believed in the death and the
resurrection.
And when Paul was brought before the
Sanhedrin, because it's surprising what
bed fellows you find when you are
opposing God. When it came to opposing
Christ, the Pharisees and the Sadducees
were in perfect harmony with each other,
buddies, bed fellows. And when Paul was
confronted later, he was in a bit of
trouble there. So he threw this gauntlet
at them and he says, "I'm a Pharisee. I
believe in the resurrection." And
remember what happened there? They
started fighting so much amongst
themselves they didn't even know what to
do with Paul anymore. It's interesting.
So this is what the ancient Egyptians
believed. So ancestor worship in most
cases is simply spiritualism of the east
which serves as the exponent of
immortality, contact with the other
world. Page 14. That's what it's the
bottom line is. And he doeth great
wonders and deceiveth them that dwell on
the earth by means of those miracles
which he had power to do. Revelation 13.
Spiritualism
is going to play a major role in the
deceptions of the last days. I will show
you slides that will stun you in lecture
that's coming up called signs and
wonders. Don't miss it
for they are spirits of devils working
miracles. Revelation 16:14. When Mary
appears
to the Christian Catholic world or to
the Islamic world as she frequently in
inverted commas does who's appearing?
Mary's asleep. Mary is asleep awaiting
the resurrection. So who is appearing?
It's a demon masquerading as Mary. And
no ma marvel for Satan himself is
transformed into an angel of life. 2
Corinthians 11:14. The devil assumes the
role of Christ. He comes as Matraa and
says, "I am your brother who through
many cycles have done this and that and
the other and what have you." What a
load of nonsense.
If he's so great because he had so many
cycles, then everybody is great
according to that doctrine because
everybody had the same amount of cycles,
right? Why should he then be better than
the others?
But they're all dead. None of them live.
So they are demonic. Satan and Mary
appearances exactly the same. Or Gia
appearances or Vishnu or SA or Lord
whoever
all one and the same. Matthew 7:22-23
Many will say to me in that day, Lord,
Lord, have I not prophesied in thy name,
and in thy name cast out devils, and in
thy name done many wonderful works, and
then I will profess unto them, I never
knew you depart from you, ye that work
iniquity, anomia, against the Lord of
the law of God. Ephesians says in 6:11,
put on the whole armor of God. You
cannot just believe bits and pieces of
the Bible. You've got to take the whole
armor that you may be able to stand
against the ws of the devil. If a spirit
being walks in here now and claims to be
Jesus Christ, as has happened in Mexico
when thousands of people fell down at a
football stadium where he appeared and
worshiped him.
Hello.
Who's appearing there? If you want to
stand against these strange
manifestations,
then we must be armed with the Bible.
Well, some people say, "What about the
thief on the cross?" Jesus said to him,
"You will be with me in heaven." Let's
go through this carefully.
And he said unto Jesus, Lord, remember
me when thou comest in thy kingdom. Luke
23:42.
That day was the Friday.
And Jesus said unto him, "Verily I say
unto thee, today shalt thou be with me
in paradise." Luke 23:43. So you see,
the thief was with Christ in heaven on
the day that he died. Well, it depends
where you put that comma because that
comma was not there in the original
text. In fact, the space between the
words was not even there in the original
text. It was one big block. So it could
also read if you shift the comma to
there to there verily I say unto thee
today shalt thou be with me in paradise
or you shall be with me in paradise. So
now we have to ask the question,
Jesus, was the thief with you after his
death on that day, the Friday. Was he
with you in paradise? Yes or no?
Well, firstly, he couldn't have been
because he wasn't dead yet. Because the
Bible says that that when the Sabbath
was drawing close to a close, uh they
were saying to the to the Romans, you
better check these guys. They're still
alive. So they went to what? Do what
with their bones? Break their bones. But
when they came to Christ, he was already
dead. Now they broke the bones so that
they couldn't climb down from the cross
on a Sabbath because it would have been
a sacrilege to chase them on a Sabbath
day. You see, that would be breaking the
Sabbath. So break their bones and they
can't do that. So firstly, he wasn't
dead on the Sabbath. He still lived past
that. And secondly, he wasn't in heaven.
Jesus did not ascend to heaven on the
day of his crucifixion.
He slept in the grave. Let's check that
out. Mary Magdalene comes to the grave
Sunday morning.
And Jesus said unto her, "Touch me not,
for I am not yet ascended to my father."
So he couldn't have been with the thief
in heaven. Because he had not ascended
to his father. But go to my brethren and
say unto them, I ascend unto my father
and your father and to my God and your
God. So early on the first day of the
week, Jesus ascended unto heaven. He
wasn't there on that Friday. And that
evening he was back because he appeared
amongst the disciples. So on that day he
went to the father and the father
accepted his sacrifice. So the thief was
not with Christ in heaven on that day.
So Christ said, "Verily, verily, I say
unto you today, you will be with me in
heaven."
God does not forget the dead. If a man
die, shall he live again? All the days
of appointed time will I wait
till my change come. Thou shalt call,
and I will answer thee. Thou wil have a
desire to the work of thine hands. Job
14:14 and 15. So he will die. He will
sleep. And Christ desires, he longs to
be with his people. He cannot wait for
the day of the resurrection. So the dead
sleep in Christ. And on the day of the
resurrection, Jesus says, "Come forth.
I'm here."
And they wake up. But now is Christ
risen from the dead and become the first
fruits of them that slept. For as in
Adam all die, even so in Christ shall
all be made alive. Christ the first
fruits afterwards they that are Christs
when
at his coming. Now the Bible says
that there was a wave offering, a first
fruits offering. Now when Christ rose
from the dead, there was an earthquake
or when he died, there was an
earthquake. And what happened? Graves
opened and the dead rose. Certain select
dead rose. And those dead are the first
fruits of the resurrection and are with
Christ in heaven. So some are in heaven
already. Then there are a few others
that are in heaven as well. Enoch never
died. He went to heaven. He was
translated. Elijah, he didn't die. He
was translated and went to heaven. Moses
died but was resurrected because the
book of Jude says that there was
contention over him. and Elijah, Moses,
Enoch, and a number of others who serve
as priests together with Christ because
there were 24 elders together, 25 elders
together with Christ in uh or in the
earthly sanctuary. And so there are also
elders serving in the courts above. So
some are alive.
I shall be satisfied when I awake with
thy likeness. We will be transformed
into the likeness of Christ. Psalm
17:15.
Yet in my flesh shall I see God whom I
shall see for myself, and mine eyes
shall behold and not another. So it's
not a ghost. I will see him as I am.
Wonderful thoughts. According to the
Lord's own word, this is all scripture.
We tell you that we who are still alive
who are left till the coming of the
Lord. So when the Lord comes, there will
be the living who are in Christ and
there will be the dead who are asleep in
Christ.
Will certainly not preede those who have
fallen asleep. For the Lord himself will
come down from heaven with a loud
command, with a voice of the archangel,
with a trumpet call of God, and the dead
in Christ shall rise first. 1
Thessalonians 4:15 and 16. After that,
we who are still alive, so the living at
the end of time, and are left will be
caught up with them in the clouds to
meet the Lord in the air. The clouds,
Hebrew parallelism, I'll deal deal with
it in a later lecture, are angels. So
the angels gather the elect and they
meet the Lord in the air and so we will
be with the Lord forever. One
Thessalonians 4:17. So that's the
biblical teaching. Christ returns, the
dead in Christ are raised, the living
are translated together, the one not
preceding the other meet the Lord in the
air.
We shall sleep until he comes and knocks
on the little grave and says, "Dr.
Martin, get up. Then I shall rise in a
moment and be happy with him forever.
The Christian hope. Page 37. That's what
Martin Luther taught.
Marvel not at this, for the hour is
coming in in that which all that are in
the grave shall hear his voice and shall
come forth. John 5:28-29.
And he that has the son, he will have
life. And he that does not have the son
of God, he will not have life. We will
have to deal with this very carefully. 1
John 5:12. Now to the King, eternal,
immortal, invisible, the only wise God,
be honor and glory forever and ever.
Amen. 1 Timothy 1:17. God is immortal,
not we. We have immortality
by grace.
Behold, I show you a mystery. We shall
not all sleep, but we shall all be
changed in a moment, in the twinkling of
an eye. When?
at the last trumpet. For the trumpet
shall sound, and the dead shall be
raised incorruptible, and we shall be
changed. For this corruptible must put
on incorruption, and this mortal must
put on immortality. 1 Corinthians 15:51
and onwards. So, we see that the Bible
is consistent throughout on this topic.
These all died in their faith, not
having received the promises. Paul lists
a whole list of great men and he says
they died without having received the
promises but having seen them a far off
and were persuaded of them and embraced
them and confessed them that they were
strangers and pilgrims on the earth.
Hebrews 11:13 the promise of the earth
made new is coming in the future. The
dead men shall live together with my
dead body shall they rise. Awake and
sing ye that dwell in the dust, for the
dew is as the dew of herbs, and the
earth shall cast out the dead. Isaiah
26:19. The biblical doctrine is so
clear. I am the resurrection and the
life. He that believeth in me, though he
were dead, yet shall he live. John
11:25. So here are these two great
distinctions. Now what about the texts
in the Bible where it talks about
hellfire?
All of these interesting things, what
happens to the wicked? What happens to
them? What is all this about? Revelation
6:16 and 17.
And he said to the mountains and the
rocks, "Fall on us, and hide us from the
face of him that sitth on the throne,
and from the wroth of the lamb. For the
great day of his wrath is come, and who
shall be able to stand?" So the one
class, the dead in Christ rise. The
living righteous are translated.
Together they meet the Lord in the air.
There's another class, the living
wicked, and the dead wicked. Matthew
10:28,
"And fear not them which kill the body,
but are not able to kill the nephesh,
the living entity, but rather fear him
which is able to destroy destroy both
soul and body in hell."
Doctrine of hell. Well, the word used
there is
what does it mean? Let's have a look at
it.
The Hebrew origin hell is the place of
future punishment called
ora
of fire. This was originally the valley
of Henom south of Jerusalem where the
filth and the dead animals of the city
were cast out and burnt. A fit symbol of
the wicked and their future destruction.
So there you have
this concordance explanation of this
world. So the word refers to the valley
where the dead bodies were burnt
destroyed. By the way, how long did
those bodies burn?
Until they were gone. Until they were
burnt gone. Now the Greek Hardes
and the Hebrew Shaw which is used in the
Bible and which is often referred to as
hell for the doctrine of hell is the
place of the dead. So it's the grave.
You go down into the pit. You go down
into shaw into the grave. You go down
into hades the grave. And it's often
translated also as hell. So here you
have the two possibilities for this
doctrine of hell. The one is
this fire that burns which was the
symbol of this valley of Henon and the
other one is hardest or shaw.
Then he shall say unto them on his left
hand depart from me ye cursed into
everlasting fire prepared for the devil
and his angels. Matthew 25:41.
Now what is this everlasting fire? These
are the symbols that are used to explain
the doctrine of hell. Now this is what
Samuel Hopskins wrote. Catholic doctrine
is the following. The smoke of their
torment shall ascend up forever in the
sight of the blessed before their eyes.
This display of the divine character and
glory will be in favor of the redeemed.
Aha. So, Catholic doctrine says that if
those burning down there, the contrast
between the redeemed and those burning
is very great and is in favor of the
redeemed and most entertaining.
Interesting. And give the highest
pleasure to those who love God. That'll
be great. So, if I have my daughter or
my son or one of them down there, this
will give me the greatest pleasure while
I sit in heaven and watch them sizzle
fits. It's kind of sick. Should the
eternal torment and fires be
extinguished, it would be in a great
measure put an end to the happiness and
glory of the blessed. That's a very
warped idea of blessing and happiness.
It's a pretty sick idea. So this idea of
the eternally damned and the eternally
blessed is a is a heavy Roman Catholic
concept. Ezekiel 33:11 says, "As I live,
says the Lord, I have no pleasure in the
death of the wicked."
God doesn't take pleasure in them dying,
but that the wicked turn from his way
and live. Turn ye, turn ye from your
evil ways, for why will you die, oh
house of Israel? God is not this
character that is portrayed there. I
have no pleasure in the death of him
that dieth. Ezekiel 18:32.
This is a sword in the heart of this
Catholic doctrine. Catholic religion
Martin page 290. The Council of Trent
decided in purgatory the souls can
themselves white their debt only by
suffering. So here he's taught another
sort of in between station. You have
hell where you have eternal torment. But
if you weren't so bad, you could burn
off some of your some of your sins
beforehand. Either God forgives you or
he doesn't.
Let the wicked forsake his way, and the
unrighteous man his thoughts, and let
him return unto the Lord, and he will
have mercy upon him, and to our God, for
he will partly pardon.
Isaiah 55:7. Is that right or not?
Abundantly pardon. As far as the east is
from the west, he will remove your sins
from you. There's no halfway station
where you need a blowtorrch to burn off
the rest that wasn't perfected.
So the doctrine of purgatory is not
biblical either. So what about the story
of the rich man and Lazarus? Well, we've
already explained Jesus was talking to
the Pharisees and the Sadducees. And the
Sadducees taught that when you died, you
went straight to heaven or straight to
hell. That was Alexandrian doctrine.
That's where they received their
training. And by the way, they also, as
we said, taught that they were going to
the lap of Abraham. And now Jesus takes
their story and he turns it upside down.
They also taught that if you were great
and good and wonderful on this earth,
and if you were one of the elect, born
into the elect society, you went
straight to to Abraham's lap. Well,
Jesus takes their doctrine and he takes
everything they stand for and turns it
upside down. The rich man goes to the
bad place. He stands for Israel who had
all this knowledge. And the poor man who
had nothing but sores, the sinful one
who waited for the crumbs, the little
bit of doctrine that could fall from the
table of Israel. He received nothing. He
went to Abraham's lap. And the ones then
down there, he said, "Father Abraham,
Father Abraham, please can I not just
send someone a message
that uh my brothers can be warned?" Now,
what is wrong with that story? People
make that a literal story. Firstly, all
the redeemed on Abraham's lap. That's
not biblical. Secondly, he's praying
asking father Abraham to do something
for him. That's veneration of the dead.
So all those doctrines in that parallel
strike directly at the heart of satis
teaching and kills it. This is a story
that turns the doctrine of the Sadducees
upside down and shows them the bigotry
of that story. that the wicked is
reserved to the day of what does it say
there? Destruction. They shall be
brought forth to the day of wroth. Job
21:30.
In the Bible, you must put the texts
together and let the plain texts explain
the not so plain ones. And these shall
go away into everlasting
punishment, but the righteous into life
eternal. Now the question is, is the
punishment going to continue forever and
ever or is the consequence of the
punishment eternal? That is the question
we must answer. And death and hell were
cast into the lake of fire. This is the
second death. Aha. So the first death is
the one that you die literally when you
die. Then you can be raised to judgment
and the lake of fire
is the second death. So you die a second
time. And whosoever was not found
written in the book of life was cast
into the lake of fire which is what?
>> The second death. So how long will the
wicked burn? Is it an everlasting
suffering? Or is the consequence
everlasting?
But the wicked shall perish, and the
enemies of the Lord shall be as the fat
of lambs. They shall consume into smoke.
They shall consume
away. Psalms 37:20.
Now the Bible says they will be burnt
and burn away. So the consequences of
the fire of the just like those animals
died out there and were burnt or those
that had burnt away until there were no
more. They will be destroyed. They will
burn and they consume away. And fire
came down from God out of heaven and
devoured them. Revelation 29. So they
will be consumed away. For behold, the
day cometh that shall burn as an oven,
and all the proud, yeah, and all that do
wickedly shall be stubble.
And the day that cometh shall burn them
up, says the Lord of hosts, that it
shall leave them neither root nor
branch. Malachi 4:1. They shall burn
away.
examples in the Bible. Turn into the
cities of Sodom and Gomorrah into ashes.
Condemned them with an overthrow, making
them an example example unto those that
after should live ungodly. Now they
suffered the consequences of eternal
fire. Did the fire burn eternally or are
the consequences eternally in terms of
Sodom and Gomorrah?
>> Is Sodom and Gomorrah still burning out
there? No, but it's gone for how long?
>> Forever. That's the Hebrew concept of
extent. Forever. Forever. The concept is
that the consequence is forever. Even as
Sodom and Gomorrah, this is Jude 7, even
as Sodom and Gomorrah and the cities
about them in like manner given
themselves over to fornication and going
after strange flesh are set forth as an
example
suffering the vengeance of eternal fire.
It's an example of the eternity of that
judgment.
They shall be as though they had not
been 16. In other words, the wicked will
one day perish and be gone. God does not
burn them forever and ever and ever. How
incredibly unjust that would be for a
short life of
wrongdoing to be eternally tormented.
That's not the character of God. That's
a character of another one. The Bible
does not teach that. The Bible is
distorted into teaching that, but it
doesn't teach that. And you shall
trample the wicked, for they shall be
what?
>> Ashes under the souls of your feet on
the day which I am preparing, says the
Lord of hosts. So here's the bottom
line.
If you have Christ, you rise in the
resurrection.
If you are alive when he comes, you will
be translated together with the
righteous. They meet the Lord in the air
and they live for how long?
>> Forever. In Christ, there is life.
Without Christ, there is
>> no life. There is death. You will rise.
You will be judged. You will know why
you will not have eternal life. Fire
comes down from heaven. You suffer the
torment of
that is being extinguished
just like that. Gone for how long?
Forever. Forever. And you shall trample
the wicked. There shall be ashes under
the souls of your feet in the day which
I'm preparing, says the Lord of hosts.
Malachi 4:3. What happens to Satan?
Does he live forever? Are we ever and
ever and ever going to be reminded of
the wickedness and the sadness of this
planet? No. Ezekiel 28:18:19 says,
"Well, I bring forth a fire from the
midst of thee." Talking about Satan, "It
shall devour thee, and I will bring thee
to ashes upon the earth in the sight of
all them that behold thee, and never
shalt thou be anymore." Amen.
>> Is that clear? It's so plain,
but it can be readily distorted if you
want to.
And the earth also and the works that
are therein shall be burned up. This
earth is going to be cleansed by fire.
Peter 3:10. The Lord is not slack
concerning his promise as some men count
slackness, but is long suffering to us
wouldward, not willing that any should
perish, but that all should come to
repentance. One chance. You have this
life to make a decision. And at the end
of this life, you are either in Christ
or you are not in Christ. If you are in
Christ, you have life. If you have not,
if you're not in Christ, you don't have
life.
They shall come forth, they that have
done good unto the resurrection of life,
and they that have done evil unto the
resurrection of damnation. John 5:29. Is
that plain?
I think it's very plain. For the trumpet
shall sound, and the dead shall be
raised incorruptible, and we shall be
changed. For this corruptible must put
on incorruption this mortal immortality.
Then shall be brought to pass the saying
that is written, death is swallowed up
in victory. 1 Corinthians 15:52-
54.
And then
once sin has been removed, sinners have
been removed.
Demons have been removed forever.
God recreates the planet. And I saw a
new heaven and a new earth, for the
first heaven and the first earth were
passed away. Revelation 21:1.
And God shall wipe away all tears from
their eyes, and there shall be no more
death,
neither sorrow, nor crying, neither
shall there be any more pain, for the
former things are passed away.
Revelation 21:4.
So rather than being in heaven and
seeing the wicked burn for all eternity
so that you can be delighted by their
suffering, there's no such sick doctrine
in the Bible. That's a doctrine of
paganism and it comes all the way from
Babylon and is taught in the world and
believed in the world by virtually every
religious system including
mainline Christianity.
And mainline Christianity has gone so
far as to bring in pagan incrustation so
that in the cathedrals of the world you
are walking into pagan temples of death.
The worship of Anubis is not the worship
of Christ. The two are mutually
exclusive.
And Christ promises that even if you are
sad, there will be tears right up until
this moment, Christ will wipe the tears
off your eyes. And then there will be
peace and happiness and no more sin on
this planet. That's the biblical
teaching on death. Now, tomorrow we can
deal with a new age movement and then we
can look at these fantastic
manifestations that we have today.
I will show you videos tomorrow. I will
show you things that you've probably
never heard of before. And I will show
you things as to who these people
actually worship because they mention
him by name. And I'm not talking about
Mickey Mouse people. I'm talking about
the prominent people of this world.
Don't miss tomorrow's lectures and come
and look at the deception that Satan has
prepared for the last days. But if you
believe what was on the screen tonight
and what was in the Bible, you will see
the deception for what it is. May the
Lord bless you as you ponder these
things. And even if you couldn't fully
grasp it all, come again tomorrow and
let us look at the deceptions. We're
going into the events of the last days
now. These are going to be thunderous
lectures. Thank you for coming. God
bless you.
Hey.
Hey. Hey.
Oh,
glory.
Heat. Heat.
Oh,
hallelujah.
go
oh.